je vais vous raconter une histoire
c'était il ya 20 ans j'avais 11 ans et
je regarde les cartes butoir
tout est focalisé ne sais pas je
regardais les têtes sort jeudi et de ses
fameux dessin animé vous avez peut-être
entendu parler dont nous vous mettez l
univers là dieu nous a promis de vos
petits fonctions nous avons mis les
assistants personnels difficiles dans la
vie de tous les jours on nous a promis
des cités qui volent nous a promis des
voitures on me l'a promis dix mois
l'adolescente
c'était dans les années soixante dix et
jean isaac asimov sélective et de
science fiction lui dans les années 80
le premier télé culte y va alors le
multivan cet ordinateur gouvernement un
ordinateur combien de temps qui va
réguler autre vie réguler votre société
les bulles et l'économie la justice est
malade il vous dira
il nous a promis un fondu de prix
alimentée par la littérature à la
science fiction
alimenté par la société d'être défendus
d'oublier la société sûr et harmonieux
est tous motivés dans un monde en paix
avec soi même et avec les autres et avec
technologie le multivan ça fait aussi
les prémices d'un vigoureux
mais cette année d'y intensifier qui
vous veut du bien
cette intelligence artificielle qui est
là à vos côtés qui vous accompagne dans
votre vie de tous les jours c'était les
années 90 ensuite on a eu alors dit nous
vous le connaissez probablement ce
fameux ordinateur super ordinateur ibm
qui elle réussit à rome
le champion du monde des échecs les
années 90 le batteur de c'est à ce
moment là beaucoup parlé on s'est dit
l'intelligence artificielle et là c'est
la fin
la machine va se passer les tribunes on
en a longuement parlé et nous a promis à
ce rôle à un déferlement
l'intelligence artificielle avec enfin
veniez jeu ta société cheveux et tout ça
comme l'a promis aux fermetures de
données dans les médias allez vous voir
ce que vous apprendrez beaucoup parlé de
bide à aborder parler d'intelligence
artificielle encore aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas parler d'intelligence artificielle
et de vous dire est ce que vous quittiez
la raison est ce que c'est une vraie
intelligence artificielle de force
quelques mois on me l'a dit quand
j'avais 11 ans aujourd'hui la question
pensez vous que leur elle nous a donné
ça les aide non est ce que vous voyez
aujourd'hui autour de vous d'un
ordinateur qui marche qui vous
accompagnent qui vont avec il pouvait
discuter avoir une conversation
intelligente on n'a pas la grosse caisse
contre eux
aujourd'hui on a eu un énorme
bouleversement sociétal principal
abonnés peuvent intégrer l'objet on a
une et on a eu huit dada on a
aujourd'hui
deux domaines outils sont en train de
placer la société et c'est mon propos
aujourd'hui vous dire où est ce qu'on en
est et qu'est ce qui manque
et je continue de promettre un certain
nombre de chercheurs comme la veille que
celle de shizuka que vous connaissez
probablement la scène alors que ce sujet
lui promet sait que bientôt nous
atteindrons la fin de l'année
c'est le moment où la lega movie ou
innovation est un loup dit bouleversé
autres atrocités va s'auto entretenir
une fois qu'ils sont sortis l'année le
nikkei fait nos valises suite en l1 et
de tissus et le dépasse donc les leurs
en place un certain qu'on se dise que
[Musique]
des intelligences artificielles forte
sms capitole avoir hébergeant a déjà
modifié le temps j'en sais pas
les chercheurs pensent que nous sommes
ici dans la peau de femme es corps de
l'innovation technologique
cet événement
nous sommes plutôt vers le palier ces
cas là on avance on avance et à des
outils qui font plaisir ni dans un cas
ni l'autre personne quand on est dans
l'accélération maximale
c'était surtout de la com et puis
j'adore comme réveil de 10 on est dans
les débuts de l'accélération de
l'innovation technologique qu'ils ont
peut-être raison
concrètement nous avons réussi à nous
avons eu des avancées écologiques est
importante
le cpu de mémoire autre ordinateur à
votre votre smartphone dans votre banque
votre poche
il est équivalent adopté balancer des
jurys calculateur disponible en deux
années d'exercice
ce n'est pas lady jane eyre mémoire cpu
elle est la deuxième grande révolution
de présenter l'état de savez que c'est
là qu'habite assez de données dans les
plus accessibles et d'ados les gratuits
il n'y a pas d'innovation sont d'une au
bélier gratuite accessible pour les
chercheurs mais aussi tous les gens qui
travaillent dans les entreprises comment
entre un troisième grande innovation
socialisation et ados l'ingénierie lundi
visant officiellement sa liste vous
pouvez régler comme vous voulez
innovation cette innovation
l'intelligence artificielle existe
depuis on va dire depuis les années 90
90 comme elle n'est pas nouveau par
contre on a un énorme d'argent a été
divisée par les géants californiens et
chinois en pseudo est en train de
prendre un coup d'avancé
[Musique]
cette voie grands points qui font que
l'intelligence difficile à beaucoup
d'importance dans les médias mais que
son credo de ces trois grandes
innovations technologiques on a fait ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
l'apprentissage profond et
l'apprentissage trop grosse et jeux
d'eau mais qui permet de replacer
a priori selon les médias lorsque vous
entendez parler d'intelligence
artificielle dans les médias au tendon
probablement ce qui est souvent tendue
derrière c'est probablement le dernier
la trentaine d'enfants et
l'apprentissage devons attaquer le
succès de l'intelligence à 13,32 mais
l'image ce qu'on peut voir un retour de
tout un saut ont encore cinq ans
comprend notamment effectivement et à
leurs élus qu'ils voient qu'ils
entendent et qui comprennent ça s'est tu
[Musique]
commençons tout d'abord par un
algorithme voit notamment effectivement
débat d'aujourd'hui qui réalise ce
qu'analysent le cortex visuel et cette
bourde et adoré pour leur donner sans
compétition s'en fout de ça ils font
leur indique qu'en voyant m et puis vous
leur donner une nouvelle image
il y est ce que ces chiens parce que
c'est un champ visuel à savoir reconnus
identité reconnaît la caractéristique
reconnaître les progrès et donc on
essaie de plage reconnaître supplée
profondément une image
au delà de l'ensemble de succès d un
accolé au jeu est effectivement
lorsqu'on part de leurs connaissances
président âge aujourd'hui les adorer ont
battu les trucs fecteau en 2010 est
assorti d'un benchmark effectivement
l'homme se trompent plus que
l'algorithme dans la reconnaissance de
visage c'est pas mal
ma deuxième pourquoi ces leçons alors le
son c'est la capacité de la comédie a
jamais ri de l'ex jaminet de la voix à
partir de textes de dire l hadopi et des
gros points capacité d'analysé et la
partie
[Musique]
reprend pied et vous parler et on a des
notions extrêmement convaincante à dos
mais qui peut parer et vous avez
peut-être vu démonstration de google et
des romans d'anna gorille qui dit qu
avec quelqu'un au téléphone je ne sais
pas si cette intelligence artificielle
de quasiment rien la reconnaissance de
parole c'est quelque chose qui est des
tables effet fortement ces dernières
années et là je vous présente donc faire
avec man une courbe qui montre
l'évolution de la performance d'un
gorille le taux d'erreur diminue et avec
une biopsie qui correspond au niveau il
[Musique]
ya six mois il ya un an 2017
on a réussi à enfin un seul homme
reconnaissance de la part d'abord
lorsque vous avez des absents la faune à
bellingham d'être un accent anglais mais
détaxant à sa place et on n'arrive
jamais le troisième jour c'est la
symbolique quand on disait mon petit
confort indique à la gauche et aux
traits de comprendre l'humain se
montrant beaucoup de choses qui comprend
comment elle peut comprendre comprends
qu'on qu'est ce que comprend mois en
question analyse des grandes quantités
de textes et commentaires des relations
entre les murs et à partir des relations
entre les mots qui commence à tisser
forme de grâce a motivés puisque la
compréhension est issu du lien entre les
mots me viennent des mots entre eux le
labory ne va simplement réussi à insérer
le sens à partir de
franchement entre deux maux il ya la
grammaire est bien là sa part adam du
grand nombre d'autres à ce qu'il avait
vu qu affiche un total de plus pas vous
corriger des traces c'est un beau
corriger votre grammaire il peut
proposer des tuyaux ni écrire à votre
place y'a pas de benchs mardi risque
comprend mieux connaître vous aider dans
la vie courante les accessits et
probablement avec un des plus connus
pour notre pays on a eu cette intrigante
il y a c'était il ya un an un an et demi
les oiseaux qui a battu les tribunes
jeopardy ne l'avait pas dire que garry
kasparov et une battue particules ou
dans les années 90 je partis cette
question pour un champion
bon vous avez malgré qu'il écoute il
écoute il est question il va chercher
il a droit dans l'immédiat la toile
comprenons c'est m c'est vrai que et
puis il répond c'est à taurinya a battu
le champion du monde du jeu vieux
continent à dori n'a pas dû l'être
humain non réfléchie du coup ils sont un
mystère a dénoncé d'ailleurs réussi à
s'adapter à toutes les interfaces de
l'ordre et selon du renoir
comment un homme reconnu lequel grand
âge j'étais jean alex l'environnement
ils voient ils écoutent et puis
comprendre
est ce que réussit à faire à traverser
d'alcool à ses amis liés à leur
environnement du manière la plus proche
aussi de ce que nous venons du lot au
quotidien
mais on est encore plus loin on s'est
dit en les algorithmes c'est bien
quant à des choses meilleures que
l'enjeu des tâches spécialité mais et si
on essayé d'attaquer des problèmes de
généralistes on attaque et les échecs
dans les indices compliqué que les
déchets est aujourd'hui à nouveau non
plus programmé au col c'était l'année
dernière a battu le champion du monde du
goût donc c'est un acte qui est capable
de prédire en avant ses coûts d'avoir un
petit côté piscicole d'anticiper
beaucoup plus complexe que reconnaître
un chien abandonné
on les a dominés qui jouent aux jeux
vidéo qui jouent à des jeux comme par
quatre de ces jeux est là la bataille
s'annonce un peu plus serrée et ce sont
des ados et des personnages ce sont des
ragots et et qui manipule qui planifie
qui pensent à faire quelque chose qu'on
futur ces accords sont principalement
des par cette crise encore comment
s'appelle la garantie sanitaire
renforcement apprentissage
cette capacité à aller comme de la datar
à l'époque le centre of canada mais
l'apprentissage par un pansement
c'est lorsque vous prenez d'abord et
vous lui dites existant au monde n'a pas
comme un enfant qui apprend à marcher ou
intrants le vélo enfant en lui disant
pour le 3d sur un vélo il faut avancer
avancer du bas-rhin avancer tous avec le
pied droit par san et le bigot chaulage
au le lait puis se relaient les
quantités bin hamman et dit moi je vais
éviter la douleur donc il faut que je
communique d'action et de cette année
john avec la tente il s'agira
renforcement on les lâche dans un monde
dont les explorer et petit à petit et ça
passe beaucoup de choses on nous promet
aujourd'hui une situation politique là
c'est une situation extraordinaire et la
meute des favoris tandis que sa perte
les novices mais est ce que c'est vrai
est ce que la série nationale
technologie ce genre de choses ce qui
s'est passé c'est que fondamentalement
ces dernières années nous sommes passés
du digitalisation que vous connaissez
tous que vous manipulez pousse ses
motivations
voilà les importants et du mali du doigt
la données médicales mais lumineux même
plus est
mais ils manipulent des confrères on
n'est pas si tu te donner à un concept
est le conseil que ça peut être un
visage ça peut être un tel sommet se
veut être une pensée avec des mots on
est passé à ne plus haut niveau mais du
coup un succès suffisant
est-ce que c'est du temps qu'un
algorithme réussissent à dire que le
vecteur qui va te croire
après c'est le même principe à deux
hommes ma femme est ce que c'est
suffisant est-ce que manipuler duplex
manipuler des mots comment on manipule
des vecteurs
est-ce que c'est suffisant comme dit
qu'on a une intelligence artificielle
des petits fours alors là c'est sa
conception pense que une intelligence
artificielle forte sans conscience
d'être en confiance du monde font
confiance de cours c'est quelque chose
d'abouti des danseurs se disent que la
tension va émerger de la puissance de
cadres et la cuisson de traitement donné
d'autres chercheurs disent que la
conscience et l'hébergement d'une
manipulation de vue logique but de sagbo
le lobby que logique formelle comme une
architecture de cerveau contre opa
les chercheurs se pose beaucoup de
questions sur comment atteindre c'est
cette intention de lancer une vraie
révolution passe à gauche
difficile c'est un débat très fortement
philosophique
donc je m'avance je fais pas là dessus
mais dix prochaines années vous à 4
attentes et nous promettre d'assumer au
de confirmer si c'est effectivement ce
dernier bénéficie de la puissance de
ganay la crise ans de traitement donné
d'autres chefs nous disent que la
conscience et l'hébergera d'une
manipulation de logique de sa gaule
logique logique forêt aux mille dards
situation de thermo contre opa les
chercheurs se pose beaucoup de questions
sur comment atteindre ces fêtes enfin
déclencher une vraie révolution
difficile c'est un débat qu'il faut que
mon philosophique
donc je m'aventure fait pas là dessus
mais les dix prochaines années vont être
attendus et nous promet d'être filmé au
de confirmer si effectivement montréal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]